now to president biden and covid
confusion
the president addressed the nation a
short time ago to try to provide some
answers about vaccination about mass
mandates
as the delta variant continues to race
through parts of the country
he's also urging the unvaccinated to
take the shot
white house correspondent peter ducey
has specifics tonight
this is a very different variant than
what we've dealt with previously
as variants spread the president's push
to get people vaccinated rolls on it's
moving like wildfire through the
unvaccinated community
and it's heartbreaking particularly
because it's preventable
but lately things have been confusing
americans have received far too many
mixed messages and muddied
communications about masks vaccines and
what risks
remain and for whom the white house
argues the science of covet is black and
white
not red and blue so they're upset with
resistance to new cdc guidance about
masks for school children or for the
vaccinated in texas and florida at a
point in
every leader's life they have to make a
decision about whether they're going to
abide by public health guidelines
to save people's lives or whether
they're going to be guided by politics
in new york mayor bill de blasio is now
hoping to ban
anyone unvaccinated from doing pretty
much anything indoors
you'll have the key you can open the
door but if you're unvaccinated
unfortunately
you will not be able to participate many
things does the white house think that
that is fair
to people who may have a religious
reason for not wanting the vaccine or
who might just be waiting for the fda to
approve it fully before they get it
the administration and the white house
and the president support steps by
localities
to to take steps to protect people in
their states and their communities
to incentivize people getting vaccinated
and the president admits
this isn't a problem that stops at the
border you just said there is no
wall high enough and no ocean wide
enough to protect us
from the virus so what is the thinking
behind letting
untested and unvaccinated migrants
across the southern border
into u.s cities in record numbers we
have not withdrawn
the order that is sometimes critical or
criticized saying that unvaccinated
people
should be go back across the border but
unaccompanied children is a different
story
because there's that the most humane
thing to do
is to test them and to treat them and
not send them back alone
vaccinations are very serious business
at this white house but there was a
lighter moment this evening the
president
mistakenly said that some states are
offering up to one hundred thousand
dollars
to get a vaccine shot and he later
corrected himself to say it's just
a hundred dollars but that if it was a
hundred k
he would have gone back to get vaxxed
three times shannon
he wouldn't have been the only one i
have a feeling peter doocy at the white
house thanks peter
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else